[Music]  Adney so paste the boiling water  japanese miso has a wonderful deep  savory richness and is brilliant in  soups  great in fresh ginger  add dried shiitake mushrooms that have  been soaked in water  season with soy sauce crack an egg added  to the broth and poached for two to  three minutes  and thinly sliced portobello mushrooms  to a serving bowl put in fresh medium  egg noodles which will heat through in  the hot miso broth add spinach  then simply spoon the broth into your  bowl  [Music]  top with the egg and fresh chopped  spring onions  so simple so good and so delicious ready  in ten minutes  super fast noodle soup with poached egg  and spring onions  [Music]